smite is the MOBA that puts you in  control of God's from mythology's all  around the world if you've played it on  pc or xbox one you already know that but  now it's time for PlayStation owners to  take a crack at it developer hi-rez  studios is bringing smite to ps4 the  free-to-play game is enclosed alpha as  of today februari 19th and a closed beta  is planned for March you can sign up for  a code on smites official website the  team at high res hasn't revealed a full  release date yet but ps4 players will  have full access to the game's rotation  of characters when it launches they'll  also get five additional gods for free  plus some exclusive skin smite has been  on PC since 2014 and on Xbox one since  2015 so a ps4 port makes perfect sense  the MOBA has already drawn 14 million  players when high-res has more to say  about the ps4 version will tell you all  about it on gamespot